-Here's the way the game works.
It's like Musical Chairs,
but instead of diving into empty
chairs,
we're grabbing
these red cups of beer.
When the music stops, one person
will be left empty-handed.
They're out of the game and have
to hang out with our deejay,
Deejay Carroll
spinning up there.
Hey, Questlove,
how are you doing, buddy?
Now, we're going to do
five rounds.
-He's asleep.
-He's so interested in this.
The last one standing
is the Musical Beers champion.
Okay, everybody,
space yourselves out,
and good luck.
♪♪
-Is it?
-Oh, boy, oh, boy.
-[ Playing warbling tones]
[ Calliope music plays ]
That way.
Don't let her fake you out
by being nice.
Why be that confident, Ryan?
-Get outta here.
♪♪
-Aha!
[ Music stops ]
No!
-Aw!
I'm out!
[ Laughter ]
-Katie Holmes ripping it
from the hand so gentle!
-A seasoned drinker,
a seasoned drinker!
-That was fantastic!
-God!
-[ Laughing ]
Alright, go up there.
-Oh, my God, that's action!
-Bridge!
-Oh, it's nice to be here.
-[ Clears throat ]
Thank you, Higgins.
-There you go.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh, my God,
that was great.
-Ah.
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Calliope music plays ]
-I don't want to be by Katie.
She scares me now.
-I know. Aah!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Aah!
Good! [ Laughs ]
[ Music stops ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You watch it!
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, Jimmy.
-Get outta there.
-Sorry, man.
-Come on, now.
-I had no option at all!
-Oh, my gosh!
-Katie Holmes is a beast!
She's fantastic at this.
-I see her technique, though.
-Oh, I gotcha. Alright.
I'm watching here. Here we go.
[ Calliope music plays ]
Only three cups left.
I'm rooting for Katie.
♪♪
Get the cup! Maybe now!
No, not yet.
Maybe!
Oh! Oh! Yep, yep.
Keep going, keep going,
keep going!
Don't look at Katie Holmes!
[ Music stops ]
-No.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Amazing.
You are the best.
She's amazing and the best.
Look at the cup. Oh, my God.
She crushed it.
Alright, alright.
Oh, here. Come on!
Come on, Katie, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two cups left! Two cups left!
Here we go!
[ Calliope music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Oh!
♪♪
Oh! [ Laughs ]
Don't move the table!
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
-Alright, here we go.
This is it, right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is it. You have to.
This is it -- the final cup.
The final countdown.
You had a good run, there.
-You can't move the table.
-Alright, good luck, now.
This is it.
Don't slip, don't slip,
don't slip.
[ Calliope music plays ]
Beer everywhere.
♪♪
Oh, my God!
No! No!
♪♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That was amazing, though.
Come here, come here!
[ Laughter ]
-That was so mean.
-Of course.
-A victim of drinking.
-[ Laughing ]
-That was amazing!
-I'm sorry.
-I'm gonna give the win
to Katie Holmes, right there.
-Absolutely.
-A good job.
You were unbelievable.
-Really good.
-Our thanks to Ryan Reynolds,
Katie Holmes!
The game works
like Musical Chairs,
but instead of diving
into empty chairs,
we're grabbing
these red cups of beer.
When the music stops, one person
will be left empty-handed.
They're out of the game
and have to hang out
with our deejay up there --
Deejay Johnson Hamburger.
Now, we're gonna do four rounds.
The last one standing is
the Musical Beers champion.
Okay, everybody,
space yourself out
and get ready.
Oh, really? There?
[ Calliope music plays ]
-Which way are we walking?
-That way. Yeah, the other way.
Don't look at me.
♪♪
Don't touch it!
-[Bleep], damn it.
-Aw!
-[Bleep]
-Duh!
[ Music stops ]
-Aw, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love you.
-And you're the tallest.
-A noogie.
-He's out.
-I'm English. This can't happen.
-[ Laughs ]
-And your limbs are much longer.
-This can't happen.
This can't happen. Exactly.
-Uh, thank you, Tariq.
-Wow.
-Oh, that was rough.
Sorry about that, Paul.
[ Calliope music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-That's a long distance,
that way.
-Oh, [Bleep]
-[ Laughs ]
-Look at this [Bleep].
-Put it back, put it back!
[ Laughter ]
[ Music stops ]
Look there!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I thought he said,
"Drink it now"!
-You got to drink that, baby.
I'm glad to lose.
-[ Chanting ] Drink! Drink!
Drink! Drink! Drink! Drink!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-He drank that.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs, coughs ]
-I don't know if you really won,
there, Jimmy.
I really don't think you won.
[ Laughter ]
[ Record scratching ]
-[Bleep]
I'm really scared.
[ Calliope music plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That's where they are?
[ Laughter ]
That was a trick.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Isn't it...
♪♪
[ Music stops ]
-Whoa!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
I tried. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Aw, God.
-Y'all ready for this?
[ Vocalizing ]
-We already made out.
-I feel like
we already made out, yeah.
This is...
[ Laughter ]
This is pointless at this point.
[ Calliope music plays ]
[ Music speeds up ]
[ Music slows down ]
♪♪
[ Music speeds up ]
[ Music slows down ]
♪♪
[ Music speeds up ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jimmy!
-[ Laughs ]
-That was so...
-Oh, thanks. [ Laughs ]
-You're brave, you're brave.
-Thanks to Jeremy Renner,
Elizabeth Olsen,
Paul Bettany,
and Sebastian Stan!